yeah it's like this whole AOC chasing
Amazon out of Queen oh right yeah
and she doesn't understand the
difference between a federal or a local
grant of three billion dollars and a tax
cut of three billion dollars the tax cut
is on what cut understanding how the
government works is but bipartisan he
had probably part about politicians
fairness she owns it either was pretty
sorry he was like last year I was a
waitress serving tacos in lower
Manhattan now I'm here and I was like
and II chose that is no surprise but
they're trying to get Amazon to come
back right you think that's gonna work
if you were Jeff besos are you going
back into that suit oh I don't know are
you gonna go back and put a target and
have a OC and her loony anti-capitalist
socialists start the hashtag boycott
Amazon do you want to risk that would
you rather go to Detroit or Philly or
Pittsburgh where they're like oh my god
Jeff Bezos you say no where everybody
who works for the government where a
Jeff Bezos t-shirt and Amazon t-shirt
for one year literally that's what I
would have done I would have if Mayor
Jason was running for amazon.com Mayor
Jason calm would literally a big
announcement coming in October October
first book it now everyone wears mayor
Jason's shirts for the first no I would
literally say to base us everybody in
San Francisco who works for the
government
bus drivers everybody if you bring
Amazon you we don't want any more people
in this city but let's say I was the
mayor of st. Louis Obispo
mmm-hmm or Pittsburgh my other favorite
city beautiful if I was the mayor of
Pittsburgh Mayor Jason and then it's not
a threat to the people who Pittsburgh by
the way I know I promised but if I did
become the mayor of Pittsburgh yeah then
what I would say every bus driver every
schoolteacher
everybody will wear an amazon.com
t-shirt or lapel pin or a logo for the
next year and we will buy everything for
the government through the portal you
get good prices
amazon.com there you go well buy 100% of
procurement will go through Amazon okay
for the year
you bring it here alright that's what I
would do really hit those 25,000 high
paying jobs to my favorite City
Pittsburgh yet acquire as part of
getting your driver's license have a
checkmark for Amazon Prime on the form I
would have there you go
every time you get pulled over by a cop
it would send Stan check out no you
would have at the bottom take a picture
of this ticket with your Amazon app and
if you're a Prime member half off your
ticket you're going 20 miles over the
speed limit just ten hundred dollar
check for Amazon Prime members can park
on the street that and more amazing
public policy advice at Mayor Jason calm
no conflict no interest I literally I
would I would put the Amazon logo on the
foot of the Statue of Liberty there you
go for the year a banner bring us how
about change her face a shows his face
no no that's too much a little too much
too far now there is a little base there
I've been there yeah yeah on the base of
the bring us your tire of your rich
bring us your tired your poor long
amasses and get free shipping
that's what I would do there you go
Staten Island here that comes issue
Island Ferry here it is now the prime
theta Prime very you can take it if you
have Amazon Prime if you don't you got a
bike to Manhattan that's it
Amazon Prime you get on the Staten
Island Ferry for free I love it